winter is coming but first let's make
sure you caught up on where everybody is
both breaker Game of Thrones season 6
episode 3 here's a reminder that I don't
do spoil the free anymore let's get to
it I'm not actually sure how this
reviews gonna turn out it may run short
or it may run more negative than I
actually intended to be because by and
large there's actually nothing wrong
with anything that we are shown in and
of itself the episode as a whole is
definitely the weakest of three we've
seen so far because frankly it's kind of
boring in a way I kind of feel they did
with this episode but they did back in
season three with the episode the maiden
and the bear with all the road when they
crammed every romantic subplot into that
episode I feel like in this episode they
crammed all the okay what's the just
sort of general piece moving a little
bit of political updating that we have
to do you know the boring parts of
episodes can we just consolidate all the
boring parts from about three or four
episodes just cram them all in this one
and that's just what it feels like I
mean everything is relevant everything
is moving things forward everything is
bringing you up to speed on something
maybe you didn't know before or pushes
in the story in the direction that it's
gonna have to go but if not a lot
happens we get a decent fight scene
thanks to the flashback through bran and
you know seeing a young Ned Stark that
was a little odd but that was
interesting and probably the best fight
this shows given us since brand versus
the Hound Varys gets a nice highlighted
seen Elena Terrell's back she didn't do
much yet but she's back i'm very happy
with that they're doing a real good job
building up the sort of the franken
mountain has this really intimidating
you think that I mean even Jamie seems
unnerved by the sand I like that ocean
Rickon I can't say I was like really
gung-ho for them to come but well Rick
in any way OSHA I was happy to see
although the circumstances not the best
I I'm just really hoping that before the
end of the season OSHA bites Ramsay's
balls off and I don't even mean that
metaphorically tenaris and we're still
stalling I mean again again the scene
was fine they actually kind of played
out kind of interestingly with the
dynamic
that's going on in that building
whatever it is I kind of like to the the
way the the older sort of formula is
she's still a Khaleesi but yeah the the
widow of a cow the way she interacted
with the Narrows away she's like yeah I
remember what I was like you so I mean
it's a decent scene but again it's just
God how long are we gonna stall her
something else I'd like I like John
coming back and it just be very
matter-of-fact about it not dragging on
it too long and we just get everybody's
reaction okay so we're gonna deal with
this now the traders hanging that was
vine made sense was earned it was weird
for me with Ollie just standing up there
mmm you know with his angry face cuz I
actually I felt really kind of bad for
ollie before I felt like he'd been
driven into a decision that maybe he
didn't want to make but he'd been
convinced it was the right thing to do
but they just made him look like a dick
before they hung him felt like an
oversimplification of the character at
the last minute just so we would be okay
with seeing a strangled child some very
cool training for aria she got her sight
back but again that just makes me
nervous cuz I I don't want her to lose
who she was just so she can be a better
killer but I'm sticking with it and it's
still cool stuff in and of itself so
hanging in there we find out who's
behind the sons of the harpy and it's
the Masters from other cities who cares
I mean it's not like that's a dumb
reveal or anything but why did you tease
it like you we were gonna reveal who the
leader was like it was a deal it's just
okay it's the guys that Daenerys has
pissed off as she's been conquering the
land yeah that makes total sense why
were we making a thing of this high
Sparrow still just being great at doing
what he does in the end I think I need
to default to Tyrion on this I think his
scene and his attitude just sort of
summed up my feelings about the episode
overall like I'm kind of bored I think
I'll drink again nothing really wrong
with this episode it's fine but this is
not an episode I would ever go back and
like spot watch just this one episode
for the fun of it yeah it's not
like I'd skip it if i rewatch this
season but there are certain episodes
you go back to because you really want
to see that episode again this one boom
this is not that it's not bad there's
nothing wrong with it it's functional it
moves the story forward but that's about
all it does so what were your thoughts
on this latest episode of Game of
Thrones whatever they were drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it do not forget to Like and
subscribe follow me on Twitter I council
of geeks check out the council of geeks
podcast on itunes and stitcher and until
next time this council is adjourned